atlanta board of education requesting
teachers be moved to the front of the
vaccination line
but the state's republican governor is
saying while teachers are a priority
for now they'll have to wait how come
well brian kemp joins us now with the
answer
governor thanks for joining us um just
uh
what is the answer and apparently
obviously you must have stated it before
but for the audience who are not aware
of this
it's a major donnie brook in your state
what are you telling these teachers
well i wouldn't uh necessarily agree
with you about a major donnie brook in
the state i mean look we'd love to be
vaccinating teachers right now we need
more supply from the federal government
we're thankful for the little bit of
good news we got over the last seven
days to get some more vaccine but we
have
two million seniors that and first
responders and other folks that meet the
current qualifications
here in georgia so we still have a long
way to go to get those vaccinated
obviously if there's
65 year old individuals that are in our
school systems they're eligible to get
vaccinate and
vaccinated now and we'd love to do
teachers but we're really following the
data and the science
and trying to protect the most
vulnerable to the virus and that's what
dr
toomey the advice that she's given me as
well
well with all due respect i see that's
what you call phase one a plus the two
million folks 1.3 million of seniors
but the teachers are saying hey you know
we're nervous we're
we're very anxious and there is a big
fuss particularly after this
apparent raid in elbert county uh where
470 shots were confiscated from a
medical center
that have been giving them out to
teachers so
there's there's something going on in
your state uh with respect to the
teachers
why why do you don't you believe they
are accepting and your
your answer to to why they have to wait
in line
well there is certainly something going
on in georgia
charles we've had teachers and students
in person
in the classroom since august and the
first part of september
in all parts of our state so the data
says that that's a safe place to be if
you do it the right way
we've supported our schools in doing
that we've given out
8.3 million pieces of ppe we've been
gaining giving out cleaning supplies and
other things to help our schools safely
reopen
but we left it up to them the complete
local control so there's a lot of
teachers that have been in the
classroom for months and months now much
like we did our reopening plan in
georgia we followed
the guidance we followed the data we put
in
a good regulations to be able to do that
and it's worked for our economy it's
working for our schools
what about the caregivers for the
elderly whether they fall in are they in
this 1a or the 1b
part of this program well certainly you
know the
the caregivers in nursing homes skilled
nursing facilities long-term
care facilities and other places they're
they're being taken care of through
operation warp speed
it is a little bit disappointing i'm
taking care of my grandmother someone's
taking care of their grandmother
what is that where do they fall in the
process
well caregivers and those are eligible
in that process look we want to expand i
would love to do that now but we got to
have more vaccine to do that
we're running 10 points above the
national average for doses given
hopefully we'll be able to expand soon
when we get johnson and johnson on board
because look that that's what we want to
do we want to get everybody vaccinated
but we're following the guidance and the
public health data right now i mean the
concern for me charles is making sure
that we have a hospital bed
for everyone in the state it has a
coveted situation or
non-coveted and we know that 65 year
olds
are more adversely affected by covid
than those that are
you know 45 or 50 or the teaching age
it's not that i don't want to do it but
we're really following
the advice of public health officials
governor kemp appreciate your time thank
you very much
thank you